foreign
hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally everybody else does
math followed by the most irrational
explanations they can find the most
irrational mechanisms they can find for
common phenomena such as gravity and
magnetism electricity and so on
anyways today we're going to do uh as we
usually do start with extension and
we're gonna move on this time around uh
with our science critic
uh he talked about whether science is
objective
and that's going to lead us analyzing
that it's going to lead us into the
subject matter today which is location
what is location
and from there we're going to move on to
some of the questions and comments
people made since last time okay so what
is extinction about uh these are the
things that we've included since the
beginning of the year for what I called
the countdown to the extinction of man
okay we started our countdown and no we
don't use the uh atomic clock the
Doomsday Clock that they use out there
uh we use our very simple very modest uh
hourglass okay I hope that's that's fine
with all of you subject matters that we
cover uh in this segment are usually uh
the ones that you see there these are
off the top of my head there are more of
them but here you see the most important
ones probably uh population pyramid
overturned the density dependent birth
rates that's happening in all cities of
the world fact that we've become
urbanized went from the country to the
city loss of genetic diversity and all
the genetic disorders that accompany
that Trend
uh the ecological pyramid overturned the
one that's really going to cause our
Extinction according to this site okay
um motor production the fact that we're
in a service mode uh within Services
we're going into internet services
primarily we consider all that as
unemployment
evaluation inflation of the currency
um unemployment Mass employment such as
Services
Unstoppable Rising debt by governments
and the possibility of nuclear war
now how's that for a listing of causes
for the extinction of man are we
supposed to last another million years
maybe a thousand years
maybe even
a hundred years
you know and so the question is how much
time do we have on our clock
okay that's the issue
anyways in this age of pronouns we had a
spell who
sent me a link
and he says you know they're deleting a
a word you know they're deleting all
these words now from the uh dictionary
or from the regular talk uh because they
offend some group out there and here's
one word that they are removing or
apparently they have removed from their
lexicon and one of the universities in
California and it's the word field
says the university Department bans use
of word field claiming it too racist
well I don't know about racism you know
here here's the
what they said about it they said it's
uh somehow they will no longer be using
this uh word field and it's because it's
anti-black and anti-immigrant okay this
change supports anti-racist Social Work
practice
okay well again I don't know about
whether it's anti black or
anti-immigrant that's not my beef with
it uh I think we should remove the word
field uh because
um it's used irrationally in
mathematical physics so-called physics
uh we don't need the word field at all
it was amended by Mr Faraday and I agree
with them not for not for because of uh
immigrants but because of ignorance
the ignorance at every University on the
planet that uses the word field and I
would not stop with the word field okay
I would continue with some other words
that I see out there and here's uh my
suggestions okay I would remove not only
field but energy time Mass Force charge
ether plasma
particle there are no such things as
particles out there if we're talking
about discrete particles point in mind
they've never been defined in three
thousand years I don't think we'll ever
get a definition for those uh how about
position we're going to talk about that
today and there you see a whole bunch of
others I think all of these words can be
withdrawn completely from the Lexicon of
um of physics okay
mathematicians use them we don't need
these words at all so you can go through
them later on but yeah these are words
that I think should all be banned from
science let alone from physics okay
so yeah I have no problem with them
removing the word field okay and again
for different reasons
uh getting back to the subject matter
um Extinction
and here we have uh Mr uh well one of
the Patricia he's one of the allies of
Putin in Russia and he says that uh they
are now fighting NATO okay in this war
that's happening in Ukraine
and you know that's uh I guess they want
to broaden the the uh the war or it
looks like that at least that's the way
they seem to perceive it in Russia okay
so uh don't be surprised in if in the
coming months uh
you know Russia
uh maybe attack something or has an
accident one of those deliberate
accidents that uh widened a war okay
might happen and uh just in case along
the same lines here we have uh another
Ally of Putin his name is and
um he's sending some Zircon missiles on
a ship that's gone into the Atlantic
okay and so uh these guys are moving
tanks these other fellows are moving uh
Zircon missiles uh it would seem like
everybody's getting ready for a big war
here okay uh whether that's gonna happen
or they're gonna sign some kind of peace
treaty is yet to be seen but do not be
surprised if the war is widened if you
look at history World War II World War
One you know everybody started you know
doing some saber rattling and then
eventually ended up in what was the
inevitable and it's like all these
people are moving their pieces on the
chessboard and uh tomorrow you never
know you know it might uh suddenly have
some accident that triggers a big war
and they'll say oh because of this now
it's not because of that they're already
getting ready for something something
big
whether it's just in case or whether
it's
you know it's gonna really happen
remains to be seen okay
and uh here we see uh on this on the
American side we see that the generals
are discussing whether there's going to
be a nuclear weapons exchange and
they're analyzing that possibility as
well whether there you see the node says
the Kremlin would likely turn to nuclear
weapons if Moscow faces defeat in the
conflict in another General right below
it says that maybe not
uh way at the bottom you see Petraeus
Russia and Ukraine will agree to a
negotiated resolution of War
let us hope Mr Petraeus is correct right
uh we sure would not like uh these
people to start pressing the red buttons
because I don't think there's a way we
can return from there as far as I'm
concerned if they start pressing the
buttons
it's game over for all of us and it's so
interesting that such few people with so
much power so much influence uh hold
their the lives of everybody on the
planet in their hands that is what is
really surprising okay but that's the
situation you know I have no control
over the red buttons uh if I did maybe I
would just remove them all but uh these
people you know they want to win a war
they think a war is winnable or maybe
they might think that they need to press
that button
and after that I don't know I cannot
imagine that there's
any possibility of returning back to
square one okay I think once they press
those buttons
you know just think about it you know
you kill a whole bunch of people
especially military of the other side
what do you think the other side's going
to do
just think about that hopefully it never
happens
anyways uh again a lot of saber rattling
going on out there here's another uh
part of the world
Tokyo undertakes the biggest military
buildup since World War II
this is the same uh Japan that said it
would never rebuild its military or go
into military uh build up uh and here
you see that they're building their
military in fact at the request of the
United States who wants Japan to
shoulder more of the costs of War and
why Tokyo says at the bottom says Tokyo
fears the loss of Taiwan
to Mainland China would threaten
shipping lanes that Supply its oil and
would undermine U.S influence in the
region you can see what the problem is
if if Taiwan belongs to China as the one
China policy now holds well that's
straight uh that uh that Waterway that's
between China and Taiwan that would be a
um part of China it would be a private
uh Lake private River whatever you want
to call it no no international shipping
would go through there unless China
allows it on the other hand if Taiwan is
a separate country well then that's
international waters and so you can see
what the fight is all about uh you know
you have uh uh shipping ships going
through there especially military ships
they say hey we're international waters
and if China gets a hold of Taiwan that
would no longer be international waters
would cause some some amount of problems
so that's part of the issue there okay
so keep that in mind but again a lot of
saber rattling all these countries are
getting ready for something
it used to be called War
Okay so
just don't be completely surprised don't
be caught with your pants now okay
okay uh here's um
another aspect of this uh tax on
Satellites May trigger military response
U.S and Japanese officials say United
States is saying that they would
immediately counter attack or take
measures if someone attacks the
satellites that control especially all
the missiles out there you know and and
what they can see on the ground you know
if there's a wall a war at the satellite
level you know we'll all be blind on
both sides I would think okay so that's
another aspect that's going on there
again a lot of saber rattling uh is it
because they just want to scare the
other side like say Hey you know I can
do this to you
or is it something more than that is are
they really getting ready for something
that each side thinks is inevitable
keep all that in mind
okay here's uh China I was talking about
this a couple weeks ago but it's always
good to remind people chips run the
world and China you know is uh
trying to get a hold of a lot of that
technology because uh
the more advanced the chips the more
things that they can do and right now uh
some countries in the west are stopping
some of the high level chips flow to
China especially if they're going to be
used in military equipment okay and so
Jen is trying to see if they can get it
do some of these tips uh on their own so
they're investing heavily in uh in chips
chip technology and Machinery remember
you need the Machinery to process these
chips as well okay okay and uh here you
have uh another aspect of this at least
from China remember it's supposedly the
second most powerful economic country on
Earth in many ways it is the engine
that's driving a lot of the economic
progress on Earth so we have to keep an
eye on China in that sense and uh
China's now is having problems with its
growth you can see how it's been
dropping for at least a decade I showed
other day that it's even dropping even
before then okay so
uh if China's the engine of the world
and China is having a slower growth as
time goes by
uh what does the future look like in
other words what are we going to see in
a couple two three four five years
and you might say Well India might come
in there Indonesia Brazil you know you
can name a few countries Bangladesh you
know uh populist countries
um
you know I don't I don't know if they
can replace China I mean they could in
the sense that they would have maybe
cheaper labor in the short term the
question is whether we need uh to
produce manufacturing anymore you know
we the manufacturing age is over and
every country in the planet is moving
into services and so maybe you know some
poor country that
um can produce something cheaper than
China might replace some of its
Manufacturing but I'm not sure it's
going to replace what China has today
completely so I don't know I would say
that uh manufacturing is dying across
the planet everybody's moving into
services and within services within
internet services
meaning that you know we're creating
this world of abstractions we're going
into what gains
a lot of programming a lot of stuff like
that entertainment
and what about the real stuff we're
forgetting about that
okay that's at least the way I see it I
don't think it's a good trend and I
think it does lead to Extinction
eventually because it uh it's going to
affect the global economy we cannot
survive we cannot keep jobs rolling on
the basis of
um uh games and entertainment Etc you
know we need we need something a little
more real than that and the world of
reality is dying it's being replaced by
a world of abstractions okay and uh
here's another aspect of that China is
set for historic demographic turn
accelerated by covid traumas and the
funny part is that I saw was the last
line at the bottom says president uh Xi
Jinping said government would enact
further policies to boost the country's
birth rate
yeah I don't know if this uh fellow is
uh on the right Planet but no China can
never recover its birth rate okay
there's no way once we uh turn the
corner and uh get into uh density
dependent birth rates meaning everybody
moves to the cities we stop having
children and these folks think uh they
can you know that there's some kind of
problem maybe it was the one child per
family policy that they instituted
sometime back and maybe that was a wrong
policy they might think and they say
well we can reverse that and we can
start growing again
it's never going to happen okay it
doesn't happen because everybody even in
China is moving to the cities you cannot
have children in the cities that's what
it's all about and aside from the fact
that you know women go out to work and
they worry more about their careers a
lot of them don't even want to have
children those that do have them late in
life so you know there's no way to avoid
what's coming which is a slower birth
rate for every single country in the
world
you know you have some Arab country some
African countries and people say oh look
at all the children they're having
no they're not having children either if
you look at the uh record you'll find
out that countries like in Africa that
used to have like seven
um
children per family they no longer have
that
now a lot in those countries as well
people are moving to the cities and
they're stop having children as soon as
they hit the cities it's got nothing to
do with being poor it's got nothing to
do with uh being black a lot of people
say oh these black people you know they
have people they have children it's got
nothing to do with that at all it's got
to do with moving to the cities
urbanization
you go to the city number two period
that's it
and um windfall said the following uh
raised an issue that's tangible or
tangential to all of this which is
climate change okay he says the
following says Australian climate
scientist Andrew so-and-so has
calculated that when you add the
industrial gases methane Etc you end up
with a CO2 equivalent to so many parts
per million okay this would seem to make
global warming and exponential function
and he thinks that because of that which
is going to cause massive crop failure
due to severe weather events more common
and as a result continued societal
conflict and finally collapse
uh no uh at least from this side we're
gonna say it's got nothing to do at all
with anything okay and we have this girl
uh
um what's her name thundberg uh and
she's uh here in Germany or was in
Germany a few days ago and protesting
because you know the German government
is gonna uh
try to see if they can revive some of
their minds or coal mines
and to make up for the uh gas shortages
that they have right now and so they're
going to see if they can produce some of
the energy through coal and so this gal
come over here and she says you know she
protested that with some other people
um
you know another that has anything to do
with anything as far as climate change
is concerned climate change is going to
take centuries to happen uh you might
disagree with me but you know there's
going to be climate change every day of
the of the year every year since since
uh we started the Earth there was
climate change is it going to affect us
now we got bigger problems bigger fires
and the big fires are the economy uh the
global economy right now I think we're
headed in a bad Direction with the
economy there's nothing we can do about
it and when it collapses not if but when
it collapses we're all dead and climate
change nobody's going to worry about
climate change after that when the
economy collapses so when these people
say look you know you have all these
gases are going up there it's going to
increase or make the process more
exponential and it's going to happen
more rapidly
and it's going to affect the crops none
of that has anything to do with anything
none of it this is going to be an
economic problem uh exclusively an
economic problem and nothing but and so
when when the global economy collapses
money is no more no one will produce
food irrespective of what the climate
says either irrespective of how much uh
coal or CO2 or whatever we have in the
air it doesn't matter we're simply not
going to produce it because our economy
is going to collapse at least that's
going to be that is the argument in this
site and so we laugh at anything related
to climate change okay
climate change has always happened and
it's not going to affect anything that
we're that's related to economics at
least not in any significant way we're
going to do it all on on our own the
economy is going to fall simply because
we're not going to create jobs and
companies are going to shut down and
when they do they're going to fire more
people more unemployment and it's just
going to be a cycle until
money will be nobody will want money
because money will have no value at all
in the world
that's that's the theory you propose
here
okay let's move on to our science critic
let's start with the science query today
because uh he raised an issue of whether
science is objective and since he wasn't
the only fellow there were others that
had something to say about that I
thought we'd start with that that partly
because it'll lead to the issue of you
know what is location how do we get from
A to B okay how do we get from A to B
okay so how did it start well I showed
him this I showed this fellow uh or I
made a video and this is what was on the
video this what he criticized I showed
him this very simple thing uh
and I don't know what it looks like to
you I'll tell you what it looks like to
me it looks like there's a rope tied
around a pulley and it's pulling up a
box
and so the question is how did the box
go up what is the mechanism that Brock
box up
you would think this is kindergarten
stuff okay that the Box goes up because
someone is pulling or a machine or
whatever something or someone is pulling
on the rope and the Box goes up I think
we all understand it just by looking at
this okay here's number two showed him
this
and it's uh Felix the Cat and he will
world's around a horseshoe throws it
into a window and breaks the glass very
simple so if uh I ask a kindergartener
how did the window break okay I guess he
would say what anybody would say well
what was the mechanism the mechanism
that is that a horseshoe went through
the window
period I mean I think it's that simple
and uh this guy had lots of problem with
that he he couldn't tell me why the Box
went up or why the window broke
see what's wrong is is there's something
wrong with his head or something and
let's put him on let him speak for for
himself here okay here he goes listen
carefully
you witness a phenomenon a box being
pulled upward by a pulley
or another a horseshoe flying through
and breaking a window
question
do you think you can objectively tell
someone what happened
do you need a PhD to explain these
mechanisms
the reality is that no one can
objectively tell you what happened there
it's especially seeing as they're just
cartoons saying something like shapes
moved around on a screen well that's
definitely an interpretation of what
happened there and if you really wanted
to you could talk about how the screen
produces light how that light was
calculated by the processor and all that
good stuff
hahaha
is this guy for real
I mean I couldn't believe it he looks at
something he doesn't understand
why it's doing it or what the mechanism
is he says because they're cartoons
what does being a cartoon have to do
with anything it's like watching a movie
I don't even a cartoon you could see
Mickey Mouse I don't know and uh you
watch it and someone asks you so what
happened uh during the uh the movie that
you just watched he says oh I have no
idea because it was a cartoon
laughs
so he cannot tell you what happened he
cannot tell you the mechanism because
it's a cartoon
but he wasn't the only one here's a
couple more people and this is what they
had to say okay and again it shocks me
that these people are even into science
I mean what are these people doing in
science they cannot tell you what a
mechanism is or why science is objective
okay here's what the first one says
simulating light with particles equals
objective I said that okay belief is
subjective and fellow says but mentally
thinking of simulating things is
suddenly objective
he just means thoughts that are certain
my God you know I I don't know what's
going on through the mountains through
some of these people's minds okay here's
another fellow he says the following
says uh again simulating light with
particles is objective believing that
this is the case of subjective and he
says clearly this example is
disconnected from the premise bill just
gave but he doesn't notice it anyway
I have no idea what's going through the
minds of these poor people
here's a same fellow I think science
reduced to explanation if the subject
understands it but only fully then
explanation becomes objective
I have no idea what these people are
understanding what's going through their
tiny little Minds here's another fellow
okay he says objective means making an
unbiased balanced observation
observation I thought I thought
observation is subjective but this all
seems to think that if it's an
observation it's done objectively uh
observed by whom you know I thought
observation means a witness and witness
is always subjective right
based on facts facts are opinion what is
a fact to you is a lie to your neighbor
which can be verified verified by whom
verified by you or by your neighbor or
your enemy who disagrees with you
so we have all these things but this one
seems to think that all these have to do
with objectivity
subjective means making assumptions
making assumptions is subjective
why why would it be objective making
interpretations based on personal
opinions without any verifiable facts
verifiable by whom by the Pope who has
to verify this to for it to be
subjective or objective objective
observations objective observation what
can that possibly mean observation is
always subjective by definition or
assessments can be used before arriving
at any decisions
decisions decisions by whom
again one person decides one thing and
that doesn't qualify as objective sounds
like you know the very subjective
scientific method is objective approach
yeah that's the only one he got right
but not because of any other things that
he said there okay
okay here's still another fellow he says
the following he says uh you seem to
forget that you're so beloved religion
science can never ever explain anything
never explained anything haha
it can describe describe magnetism or
gravity and many other phenomena but it
cannot explain them in all aspects let
alone understand them
my God and uh yeah I think he got it
from a fellow like this fellow here who
was a professor or is a professor
uh one of the universities and that's um
Donaldson he's an Emeritus Professor uh
Pennsylvania University there and so
science doesn't explain science
describes so I guess that's what this
fella is referring to okay
okay so uh why does he think that well
because
um for 400 years it's been the
mathematicians who ran the show and
still is and so mathematics can only
describe and therefore
science has become a synonym of
mathematics which they call mathematical
physics
has nothing to do with physics it's just
mathematics it's the unification of math
with physics which is irrational you
cannot unite math with physics ever math
can only describe physics can only
explain okay and so uh yeah this person
believes uh whatever he was told you
know a little brainwashing maybe a
little hypnotism there at the bottom uh
that science is about describing because
we cannot explain
and yeah a lot of people have these
thoughts and because of that he reaches
you know these irrational conclusions
one of them there is if a wave appears
as a particle just because we humans
observe it like for example the double
slit experiment that means as humans uh
us humans have an effect on the
experiment or phenomena that we observe
you know this comes from Quantum that
says that the Observer affects the
experiment and these people just parrot
whatever it was fed to them and they
don't have any mental capacity to even
think whether any of that is rational
you know they just repeat and say well
it was proven by the mathematician they
call them scientists you know it says
therefore we can uh obviously not be
objective because of this right and if
humans cannot be objective human science
and that includes the so-called
scientific method cannot be objective
you know these are people who are told
that you know particle can be a two
places at once and if it weren't true
computers wouldn't work
and they just believe it they swallow
this like candies
you can sell them the Empire State
Building
twice
they're so gullible they never question
anything coming out of so-called science
they think all that is true they say GPS
wouldn't work if relativity were wrong
that's the word they use wrong
they don't realize it's irrational let
alone wrong we don't have to worry about
wrong because it's irrational but they
don't realize that they say look GPS
wouldn't work if relativity Theory were
wrong
it never occurred to them that what
relativity says is that
um time can be bent that time a concept
can be bent and that warp time is
gravity and so on you know that those
kinds of statements
and it's like they tell them this and
they they accept they say Well it comes
from Authority it comes from people at
the universities the scientists so
they have no argument they don't even
raise an eye they don't even suspect
that it could be irrational so they
accept and they just repeat it they
parrot it
okay so here's a summary more or less of
what all these people are saying
regarding objectivity whether science is
objective uh what is a mechanism
subjective you know the uh we have the
uh pulley there pulling on the uh box
the Rope around pulley and we have the
um
the Horseshoe going through the window
and they cannot tell me what the
mechanism is they say it's subjective
and you say well why is it subjective
and they say one one of the first guys
the signed critic he says it's a cartoon
so therefore that's not science and so
he doesn't know what happened because
it's a cartoon
another fellow says it's a thought
experiment you know it's not real it's
not out here it's just like in your mind
and that's why it's subjective
it's just a simulation
uh it wasn't observed you need to
observe it who I don't know but he says
you need to observe it I give some
authority to tell them that he observed
it and it's correct and he's got to
believe it I guess that's called
objective
it wasn't verified Again by whom or that
it's just an assumption these are the
words they use to say why uh those
mechanisms
are not objective why Science Why
physics is not objective
okay
um
where do you get all this from
uh it's got to do with this with the
definitions we have coming out of the
dictionaries they're not clear-cut
we don't have good definitions we have
irrational definitions for the word
objective and subjective because we have
a hundred definitions for each one of
those words and people take bits and
pieces that they uh identify with the
word objective and so here you have one
definition says not influenced by
personal feelings so someone might think
that's objective okay if it's not
influenced by personal feelings but then
uh it continues as interpretations or
Prejudice based on facts unbiased and
objective opinion so you know if if
there's an opinion and someone declares
it to be objective it's an objective
opinion then it's objective
uh and I say that's a you have a
contradiction in terms that's an
oxymoron an objective opinion because
opinion is the opposite of objective and
vice versa they're antonyms
uh then you continue dealing with things
external to the Mind rather than with
thoughts or feelings so they think that
if it's in the mind it's subjected
and belongs to the object of thought
rather to the then to the thinking of
subject okay
and finally existing independent of
thought or an observer as part of
reality uh so here you have an objective
opinion here you have an observer uh you
know existing independent of an observer
okay uh well this other fellow said that
you need to observe it here it says the
opposite so it depends on what part of
this these definitions you identify with
objective and obviously peop people grab
different words from those definitions
and each one thinks that this is what
objectives means to me this is what it
means to you and so on and subjective is
more or less the same thing but just in
the opposite mode like existing in the
mind there you see it
so this is the problem the problem is
that we have many criteria for these
words and and that's really what people
threw at me they said look uh it's
subjective because it came out of the
Mind
or it's an assumption you know things of
that nature
that's got nothing at all to do with
objective or subjective
okay so let's get it right okay
here's my definition of objective and
subjective okay objective free of
interpretation
what is subjective belief opinion that's
subjective
okay we have it very straightforward
very clear cut no other definition is
accepted okay
so uh once we've got there okay we got
it all right free of interpretation
hey what does that mean let's let's look
at a couple of examples again see if we
can get back to square one with this
volume okay here we have the pulley
again okay
please tell me the mechanism of what's
bringing the Box up
hopefully everybody on the planet and
everybody in the universe that has
two cents of mind at least says that the
box is being pulled up because it's
being pulled by a rope that's run
through a pulley that's the mechanism
it's an objective mechanism now if you
didn't understand it for whatever reason
then I cannot imagine we clarify it so
that you do understand it
nobody is allowed to leave
the meeting room the conference room
until everybody is on the same page
everybody sees eye to eye on what the
mechanism is that the presenter
presented
okay he gave a dissertation on how the
Box moved up and he says the Box moved
up because of a rope pulled on the box
through a pulley
that's the mechanism everybody should
understand what he just said and there
you have the picture there should be no
uh alternative
okay now you might have a different
Theory you might say well it was uh
something from the bottom maybe there
was a air that pushed it up
that's a different mechanism no problem
you can you can have your own mechanism
that's a different mechanism it's
another objective mechanism that we all
understand once you explain it or you
show us what you're talking about you
say look air pushed it up great no
problem but the one that the presenter
gave his dissertation was that a uh
someone pulled on the rope and the Box
went up that was the mechanism he
presented that's the one we all have to
understand in that sense the mechanism
he presented is objective no one can
have a different interpretation of what
he just said
if you have a different interpretation
you might disagree with him say look uh
it was pushed from the bottom right you
explain your mechanism you say it was
put From the Bottom by air or whatever
wind
that's a separate mechanism again you
explain it you show us the picture it's
also objective everybody should leave
their conference room with under by
understanding what you proposed we
should all be on the same page we cannot
say well I didn't understand that
if you didn't understand it we'll
explain it again until you do
okay and if you have a different opinion
we could care less we're talking about
his mechanism that one is objective
okay it's objective because it has
nothing to do with the mind or whether
it was a cartoon or any of that nonsense
that all these people mentioned it's got
to do with the fact that the mechanism
the guy proposed the theorist proposed
we all have to understand what he said
we may disagree with him irrelevant the
point is that we all have to understand
that mechanism that's what's called
objective here and here we have again a
second uh problem there
uh how did the window break
hopefully we all say the same thing
window broke when a horseshoe went
through it that's the simplest way to
put it
okay the window broke because a
horseshoe went through it everybody
should say the same thing everybody
should understand the same thing that's
what the district the presenter uh
talked about that's that's his theory
okay so the mechanism is objective okay
did it come out of his mind yeah who
cares has nothing to do with it is it an
assumption yeah and again we don't care
about that
the question is the mechanism is that
objective
did we all understand the same thing or
what he's proposing hopefully we all do
unless you are mentally [ __ ] then we
have a different problem you got to see
a psychologist a psychiatrist you know
that's different
but we should all understand a mechanism
the presenter presented that's the point
okay
so here we have a mechanism
okay
what are you seeing what is what is the
theorist proposing hopefully we all see
the same thing we see a ball rolling
around a depression in a fishnet
that's that's what's being shown that's
what's in front of us that's objective
is it is it subjective because it's a
cartoon because it came out of the Mind
of a theorist because it's not out here
because it's just in the picture it
doesn't matter the mechanism that he's
explaining is objective
that's the point and here you have uh Mr
Brian Graham and he explains that
exactly he says look if you want to know
how gravity works why the moon doesn't
run out of the solar system well there
you have the mechanism the mechanism is
objective he's saying look there's a
depression in space-time this fishnet
this canvas whatever you want to call it
and the moon rolls around that
depression because it has no chance of
doing otherwise no problem you don't
have to agree with it you don't care if
it came out of his mind you don't care
if it was Einstein who came out of it
and he's just parroting none of that
matters
and the fact that it's a cartoon doesn't
matter either the important thing is do
you understand the theory he is
proposing the mechanism he is proposing
we should all understand the same thing
if someone doesn't we clarify whatever
the fellow doesn't understand until he
does understand what buying green is
proposing that's the way it works that's
called objective objective means we all
interpret exactly the same thing before
we leave the conference room that's what
it means
okay we all have to understand the same
thing from the presenter
it's got nothing to do with whether it
came out of his mind whether it's a
cartoon whether it's in uh in a movie
not out here none of that has any
bearing on the word objective it's free
of interpretation you are not allowed to
interpret something else from what the
presenter just uh finished you know
giving the crowd okay everybody's got to
understand the same thing if you don't
understand no problem we clarify the
mechanism so that you do understand but
when everybody leaves we cannot have you
leave the room until you understand it
once you understand it you're in with
everybody in the universe uh because
everybody should be on the same page
okay that's what it is okay here's
another uh trick that Mr Brian Greene
gave okay this is another theory he says
that uh the moon doesn't leave the Earth
because it's tied like as if by a rope
okay that's what he Illustrated
you should all interpret the same thing
that's what he's proposing there in this
Theory okay there's no warp space here
where where space time right now
everybody should interpret the same
thing that Brian is offering he's saying
the moon doesn't leave the Earth because
it functions as if it were connected by
a rope to the Earth
okay so this is a different mechanism
that he proposed or speculated upon it
doesn't matter the point is when you
leave the conference room you can say I
know what he was talking about he was
saying that the Moon is like if it's
tied by a rope to the Earth and the
Earth swings it around and that's why
the moon doesn't leave the solar system
that's what you should interpret doesn't
mean you agree with him doesn't mean
that it came out of his mind and it's
cartoon uh none of that mattered that's
not out here none of that matters you
have to understand the mechanism he's
proposing whether you agree with it or
not okay we're just trying to understand
what it is that he's proposing
do we understand that part at least okay
so here's a mechanism okay hopefully all
of you can figure out what the mechanism
is here okay let's look at it okay we
have this astronaut and he's carried to
Earth by an Angel hopefully that's what
you see there
I mean it's a very short video hopefully
you can figure it out so what is the
theorist proposing what is his theory
he's saying that gravity for example if
that's what he's talking about is
mediated by angels that is his angels
that carry astronauts to Earth or maybe
the Earth around the Sun or whatever
okay that's what you should be
interpreting
because that's the only possible
interpretation from what the theorist is
proposing here you cannot say well what
he talked about is that
um you know the Earth is that the
astronauts tied to the Earth by a rope
you cannot say that because that's not
what you see there that's not what the
theorist proposed
okay so this is the issue that's why
science is mechanisms are objective
you cannot avoid that science has to be
objective in that sense you have to
understand what the theorist proposed
what he was talking about if you didn't
understand it we clarified some more
okay
and um
so here's my theory okay and I'm saying
the astronaut Falls to Earth and we and
I show this and you say well what did
you mean here Bill did you mean that uh
those are elastic bands and he is being
pulled to the Earth because all these uh
rubber bands are somehow pulling on him
and so that's where I have to clarify to
you no that's not what my theory is
about I'm saying a different Theory I'm
saying that as the astronaut Falls to
Earth all the ropes that from every
single one of his at the atoms of his
body which is tied to every atom on
Earth is simply uh Fanning out so it's a
different mechanism that I propose and
if you didn't understand it I clarified
to you so that you finally do understand
what I'm proposing I'm not asking you to
believe it I'm not saying that it's uh
subjective because I dreamed of it or
because I put it in a cartoon or because
it's on the screen instead of out here
none other has any Merit whatsoever the
only issue here is did you understand
the theory if you didn't understand the
theory I clarified until you do
understand it and then everybody
understands the same thing from the
theory then it's objective okay if you
did not understand it well the mechanism
is objective but you have a problem
until you do understand it and you know
are on the same page with everybody else
okay so there is no interpretation your
interpretation is only to understand
what the theory is proposed hopefully we
all understand the same mechanism when a
theorist explains his theory okay that's
the point of the word objective okay
free of interpretation okay so once
again here's the
definitions objective free of
interpretation on the other hand
objective means oh I believe in your
theory or I don't believe in your theory
your theory is wrong your theory is
Right correct or whatever that's when we
have subjectivity not because we have a
cartoon or anything related to cartoons
or because it came out of the mind or
because it's an assumption or because uh
there was no Observer
present with authority to say to tell
you what to believe so none of that has
any bearing free of interpretation you
should look at a mechanism and recognize
what the theorist is proposing
straightforward
okay so why did we mention this well
I've been talking about a tool
in the last couple weeks and then I
called the
um
Universal movie
and when Paul says why do we need the
universal movie
and so we need to start there before we
can move on to location because these
people are still need to go through
kindergarten before they get to first
grade let alone the college these people
want to jump to college and say let's do
physics bill
no no we can't because you still don't
understand the language okay so you need
to understand the language before we can
move on to something a little higher
than what your brain can tolerate right
now okay so this fellow says the
following he says what makes the
universe anything like a movie that you
can pause to get a frame I've never seen
a frame before can you please explain
the concept and why you need this
concept for physics
is the universe an object or a
relationship between two or more objects
also known as concept or is it both
help me understand rational science
are these people for real
okay so uh let's go with that second
question first let's find out what a
universe is why the universe is a
concept and why you cannot say treat
Universe the word universe as a noun in
physics universe is not a noun and no
concept is a noun okay in physics
physics the only things that can become
that conservative nouns are things are
objects or you know those things those
uh those uh that which has shape or
those which have shape those are the
only ones that qualify as nouns you
cannot use
verbs as nouns in physics okay and so uh
here we have a universe what is universe
universe is space and matter
okay
and we treat space as a physical object
we treat matter as a physical object
temporarily only for the purposes of you
of uh defining universe so we have a
relation between two objects we treat
space as an object and matter as an
object we have this relation we need
both of them to define the word universe
um so some people say relativists that
the you know they put an article in
front of the word Universe the universe
is expanding
totally irrational uh statement you
cannot say that the universe is
expanding you can say that space is
expanding if you treat space as a
physical object in your theory you're
going to assume that space is a physical
object and you say space is expanding
okay we can all understand that you know
like a balloon or maybe a bunch of water
that's expanding or whatever okay you
can do that
and let your theory fine that's that's
what you're going to present that's fine
so you can say space is expanding you
can also say that's matter it's not
expanding matter is like a hand grenade
it's exploding and you know all the
debris is
um uh growing apart from each other
every bit from ground zero that's not
expanding not not in the sense of a
balloon expanding okay you can say it's
exploding maybe okay maybe that's a
correct word but for sure you cannot see
the universe okay because universe is a
Concepts Concepts don't extend expand
does love expand you can say love
expands what does that mean in physics
has no no uh relation to physics
whatsoever to say that a concept spans
okay so it's irrational to say that the
Universe expands either space expands
which is really what they're referring
to because they're saying that since the
Big Bang is space which is you know
expanding space time this concept okay
fine we'll treat it as a physical object
for the purposes for the instant
purposes we can say that space time
assuming it's some kind of balloon is
expanding okay we understand it so
balloon death's expanding but not not
the universe because the universe
includes the particles in other words
every atom meaning every Galaxy every
Star every everything out there every
thing which is not space
so you cannot say that this relation
between space and matter are both
expanding because what you have is a
relation that is expanding so it's
irrational to say that the universe is
expanding
which is what relatives say they use
that those terms constantly okay here we
have
um
the second part now or the first part of
this fellow's uh query okay uh why do we
need it we need the uh Universal movie
because we need to establish the
difference between static Concepts and
Dynamic Concepts okay static concepts
are those that can be found that can be
imagined or created or invented for a
single frame of the universal film
in that single frame every object in the
universe every atom in the universe has
a certain distance from every other atom
nothing is moving not even an electron
moves in that frame of the universal
film
but when you have uh those bottom ones
like motion plasma Etc ether field and
so on you need these two frames of the
movie okay you need more uh more than
one frame
and so the the issue that we've been
dealing with is those upper ones the
object you can see any object in there
is just a single picture of one object
uh could be an atom could be an electron
could be in a galaxy it doesn't matter
you can you know have whatever object
you want in there uh distance the
separation between all objects and today
we're going to be looking at location
okay so uh those are static Concepts but
you cannot use any of the Dynamic
Concepts because those involve at least
two frames of the universal movie you
need to have to what we're going to call
today locations in order to have any
kind of motion okay so the universal
movie allows us to uh look at a single
frame where nothing is moving and that
allows us to identify First the objects
and all the static Concepts that we're
going to be defining such as distance
and today location
okay so one file says uh I guess you can
see how these people are lost why we
need the universal move it says distance
the magnitude of displacement between
two positions
aha the distance between two positions
is not the same as the distance traveled
between them
but he talked about displacement between
two positions but he says displacement
is not distance traveled I well what is
this placement I thought this placement
was distance traveled what's the
difference
uh distant travel is the total length
now he's talking about length of the
path traveled between two positions
so uh this photo seems to go around in
circles he says that uh you know um uh
the magnitude of displacement between
two positions okay and then uh and then
positions is already a distance traveled
and that's also the path traveled and he
says that's the same thing as the length
so the question is what is he talking
about
and says distance traveled is not a
vector
in fact it is because uh Vector well not
the vector of physics but the vector of
mathematics mathematical physics uh the
vector is a number line and uh number
lines are all distance traveled all of
them now a single number line is
anything other than a distance travel
and distance travel defines how much
path an object has covered yeah how much
path meaning how many meters how many
feet
so you're measuring tiles you're
unrolling the measuring tape so many
meters so many tiles so many inches so
many whatevers
and yeah that's what it is and then he
says in a period of time meaning again
we're introducing more Dynamic Concepts
time is a dynamic concept
so this is always just going around in
circles he doesn't realize that distance
just separation has nothing to do with
anything that he defined here
but that's him here's another fellow and
he says the following he says uh the
universal movie is a concept that
necessarily moves
necessarily moves by defining existence
as moving
I have no idea what's going through
these these people's minds
uh where is we have a single frame
nothing is moving within a frame and
existence is defined as a static concept
meaning only within what happens or
happens with quotations right what is
there in a single frame
okay so we have physical and presence
when his object the other one is
location those are two static Concepts
they all fit in a single frame you don't
need two frames for that existence has
nothing related to motion there is no
um provision for motion in the word
exists no provision for time either okay
so I have no idea what this how what's
going through this foul's mind
okay uh another fellow he says he tries
to Define motion he says the following
he says motion is the property of what
gets from point A to B over time
so to Define motion
uh he's uh he's gonna use time
turns out that you cannot Define time
without motion
and memory for that matter but that's
the second issue but you cannot Define
time without motions he's going to use
time to Define motion
what's the problem with all these people
the problem is very simple well there's
a couple problems let's go through the
list of problems but here you will see
why okay they never learned how to
define words scientifically
in fact very few people if any out there
have uh not a single dictionary out
there has learned to define the key
words of physics in a scientific Manner
and that's why in mathematical physics
there is not a single word that is
scientifically defined okay they dismiss
definitions as semantics when you uh
bring up uh arguments saying well what
did you mean by exist and what did you
mean by this and by that they say oh
you're raising semantic arguments I
didn't come here to do grammar I didn't
come here to do uh English uh that's for
English Majors Librarians I came here to
do physics
you know like the uh Chinese fellow and
he comes to uh I don't know Texas
and he asked the text and he said why do
all people say y'all y'all this y'all
that
well let me explain to you what y'all
means uh let me Define it for you no no
I don't want to I think I'm here to
learn grammar I just want to know why
everybody calls everybody y'all I came
here to look at the Customs at behaviors
and people are saying y'all y'all y'all
y'all all the time yeah but let me
Define it for you so that you understand
why people say y'all I said no but I
don't want to understand that uh how do
you come here to do grammar and these
people are the same
so say you know uh what they do they
copy paste definition from the
dictionary you know uh ancient
definitions they look at uh etymology
you know where does this word come from
what did our how did our uh ancestors
create this word why did they create it
what is the origin of this word
it's got nothing to do with anything
because it was misdefined from the start
then we have no use for that word
especially those keywords that we're
going to use in science
if it's a common word that has no
importance then we can use the common
word and say okay where did it come from
that's fine you know that's history but
if we're going to use a word that is key
in physics like object like exist like
distance like location
hopefully we will not use the dictionary
any word that was defined by our
ancestors because they had no clue what
they were defining that's the issue so
we cannot say well what is the etymology
of this word we don't care
if it's broken we're going to fix it
okay and we don't care what everybody on
Earth votes for okay so we don't use
tradition we don't use democracy we
don't use Authority none of those
arguments are valid
if it's broken we fix it we redefine it
in such a way that we can use it
consistently meaning scientifically okay
but above all never learn that you must
define static Concepts before you define
Dynamic Concepts not one of these bozos
of the past none of these famous
scientists famous physicists famous
philosophers not one of them ever
figured it out you need to define static
Concepts before you define Dynamic
Concepts and that's the role of the
universal movie You Must define static
Concepts before you find a static
concept before you define dynamic ones
okay
so this is where the problem begins and
so we we have a a word that this one of
these fellows use position
and you know in in mathematics uh they
confuse position or a lot of people say
you know they never Define location they
use the word position
and they don't realize position as
defined by the mathematicians is an
ordered pair at its simplest form right
in order to appear in order to pair is
not a um is not a point it's not a
location it's not a position which is a
static concept it's quite the opposite
in order to pair gives you a way to get
to there to that point to that location
okay and here you see it okay here's the
definition one of the things you find
out there but they're all the same okay
an ordered pair is used to represent the
position of a point
and there you see an example okay two
four okay so if you go on the x-axis in
One Direction on the y-axis and the
other well then you end up at 2 4.
so is position two four
uh you know where that dot is no
position is how to get there because
it's represented by an ordered pair
okay so this is a position okay here's a
graphically so that you can understand
it let me get rid of this one here
okay
here you see what position is
uh location physics it's a qualitative
concept where's the treasure chest
that's what we want to know and uh it's
a static concept and all we have is a
separation from in this case the
treasure chest to every object in the
universe just a separation
what is position according to math well
it's how to get there
you know it's the instructions how many
steps you got to take you know to the
right and how many North in order to get
to the treasure chest that's what
position is
for the purposes of physic position is
uh an irrelevant word so we don't need
it at all because position is the object
itself it's the volume you could say
occupied by the object if space were an
ocean so to speak so if you have a fish
inside the ocean position is if you took
the fish out whatever he leaves behind
as as the volume that's positioned it's
a exact site occupied by an object
that's position therefore it's an
irrelevant notion we don't need position
at all unless you want to consider it a
synonym of location but for that we have
location and locations is a qualitative
concept that just says look it's all
these separations from every object in
the universe Mother Nature doesn't use
measuring tapes okay she doesn't know
what a meter is what a foot is she
doesn't know a kilometer or whatever
mile
she doesn't use any of those Concepts
and she doesn't care about him all she
wants to make sure is this object over
here separated from that object over
there this one's twirling around that
one she does qualitative stuff only
mother nature never went to school she
doesn't know math
okay she's completely ignorant and
Method could care less she doesn't make
relations she just moves objects around
we need to understand how she does it
that's the purpose of a physicist you
gotta tell me how gravity Works how she
does that magic trick for that we do not
need any math we do not need to know how
many meters how much time how much
distance uh how fast it went you know
how much it weighs we don't need any of
that we just need to know or understand
how she does that magic trick okay you
don't need a man you don't need to
um
no math to understand how a magician did
a trick
he cuts the lady in half or he does
something with cards you wouldn't know
how he did the trick
do you need to take a college course in
math to understand how he did the trick
no he just shows you how he did the
trick if he's nice and you'll learn how
to do the trick that's how simple it is
that's what we want to do with Mother
Nature we or father Universe you know we
want to know how they do their magic
tricks for that you need no math
whatsoever so we don't need position we
don't need to know how to enroll the
measuring tape or how many meters we
don't need to create standards such as
as the meter or the killer kilogram or
or time you know at the second we don't
need any of that
we just need to know the mechanism and
that had better be objective okay so
here we have uh location okay what is
location set up distances it's just
separation
distance is separation as we covered the
other day and what we have a separation
between for example the cube there and
the baseball bat the gun plant balloon
frisbee
Etc
that's the location of the cube in the
universe
okay you can take it as far as you want
you can look at a single atom you can
look at the cube from every atom in the
universe you can you know you can chop
it up wherever you want you can also
look at a system and say well like in
this case here you only have a few
objects and say what's the location of
that Cube well it's at a separation from
the uh baseball bat from the gun from
the table Etc
that's the location of that object it's
a qualitative stuff because you're going
to explain a mechanism how the cube
maybe fell to the table for example and
for that all I need to know is its
location I don't need to have I don't
need to understand how many meters away
it's from the table
I don't need to measure anything okay
and physics again versus mathematical
physics
so here it is again okay uh the reason
we need the universal movie is because
we're going to be D we need to isolate
the static concept from the Dynamic
Concepts people have a lot of trouble
with that because they confuse the ones
at the bottom for physical objects they
think plasma is a physical object and
they use it as a noun they say oh plasma
did this and plasma did that they also
do it with electricity they say
electricity is the cause of gravity you
cannot say that okay like the electric
Universe uh says no you cannot use
electricity as a noun and say that
electricity causes gravity you got to
identify what the object is okay and
hopefully it's not electricity anyways
because electricity not only is a
process but it's a one-way process where
the beads move from atom to atom the
electron beads and how you can pull with
that how you can create attraction with
that well good luck with that one
anyways uh the universal movie gives us
all these static Concepts that you have
at the top and we separate them isolate
them distinguish them from the ones at
the bottom which were all Dynamic
Concepts okay and location as you can
see is at the top it's a static concept
it's the set of distances distance being
what measurement meters kilometers feet
no it's separation qualitative
separation the set of those separations
gives us location
and eventually we're going to use
something to do something with both
distance and location once we understand
what those two words mean in physics
physics not mathematical
okay
okay so let's move on to some of the
questions comments people made even
though I covered a few already but here
is uh some others that were tangential
to the subject matter today here's one
fellow says I understand what you're
saying but your rope hypothesis is
implicit
list well what's the problem the problem
is this foul uh did not he gave us an
opinion but he gave us no explanation of
why he thinks this
he says it's physically impossible well
for that we need to understand what the
word physically means in his statement
and there we have we do do you find the
word physical okay it's that which has
shape
and so we cannot imagine what's going
through his tiny little brain okay
because it's obviously not physically
impossible because because there you see
that what you see in front of you it has
shape okay you have two atoms Bound by a
rope
uh
uh rope light pair of plank threads
anyway you want to look at it we call it
the Rope no problem you can call
whatever you call it X I don't care
but you can see that the x that little
line that unites the two atoms is
something that has shape
okay so if it has shape it's physical
so what do you what does he mean it's
physically impossible looks like it's
physically possible because I
Illustrated it
so uh the only way he can uh really make
his case if he defines physical or
physically for us then we would
understand what he's talking about what
does he mean by physically
and until he defines that we have no
idea what's going through through this
tiny little mind okay so yeah that's
where where the problem starts for him
here's another fellow he talks about
field he says uh and Sophie if a field
is the only conceptual math magic uh-huh
how is it that Fields damage computers
field damages computer
that's like saying love damages
computers or thought
damages computers uh you know what is it
conscience maybe a Buddhist would say or
something like that I would say my
conscience you know
breaks my computer
how do you do that with a concept you
know
you can't do it so Fields cannot do it
in fact he says Concepts don't have
physical presence that break computers
you're totally right yeah you can't use
a concept like field to break computer
so what do you mean how is how does a
field damage a computer he says a field
is an Energy's interaction it's an
interaction
it's a quantity and so if it's an
interaction a quantity or whatever those
are Concepts how can it how can a
quantity damage a computer
and when you look it up you find the the
word Fielding quantity right so it's a
quantity that has a value for each point
in space and time yeah quantities cannot
damage computers so we don't know where
you got this idea that a field
damages a computer that's that's what
your problem is okay you got to tell us
how how a field physically damages your
computer okay show us the movie and
we'll identify the field identify the
computer the component that it's going
to affect and then we can say okay we
can see the mechanism of how this field
that you call a field whatever that is
affected the computer how it affected
the component inside the computer so I
don't know maybe you find a chip on a
transistor we'll take it to whatever
level you want so you find a little
transistor there you know maybe a byte
and you say the field hit it
or came in contact or interacted with it
okay then we know what a field is but
you got to show us the field first okay
please show us the field you can point
uh with a link
to a place where it shows a field and we
can say okay we know what what you're
talking about okay other than that if
you look up the word field says it's a
quantity and quantities don't affect
computers not physically at least you
know okay so here same pillar I think
existence as applied to a physical
objects requires measurements
you need a measurement to to say that
you exist
so if no one measures you I guess you
disappear you you don't exist
exists having objective reality yeah the
problem there is that reality is a
synonym that exists so all you did was
you know chase Your Tail around you said
realities exist exists is reality and
you can continue doing that all day long
so yeah people don't know how to define
words scientifically and that's why they
run into these truck problems okay
okay um
fellow says says uh please describe the
difference between continuous time and
discrete time
discrete time
I have no idea what this poor fellow is
talking about time is a dynamic concept
you need at least two frames in a
universal movie okay so there is no such
thing as discrete time all we're saying
is that if we stop the universe so that
there is no more time then you have a
single frame in the Universal movie
there is no time in a single frame there
is no Motion in a single frame
and he says what is time fundamentally
in physics
well time is uh not used in physics we
do not use the word time in fact it's
one of the words that started today
saying that it's got to be uh removed
completely we don't need the word time
at all in physics okay because physics
is about explaining
mechanisms and we have no purpose for
the word time when we explain a
mechanism
you can explain a mechanism we don't
need to know how much time passed one
minute one second doesn't matter we need
to know the mechanism okay so yeah we
don't use the word time in physics at
all okay we get rid of the word time
it's not an important word it's not a
critical word it doesn't form the
foundations of physics you don't need
time at home seconds minutes hours
nothing
uh the closest maybe you can use maybe
is year but only to describe that it's
the rotation the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun we don't need the word
year either at least not in a numerical
sense quantitative sense
okay uh now fellow says
the phys in physics a photograph is an
object and a frame is a concept
haha what makes the universe anything
like a movie that you can pause to get a
frame
are these people kidding me
it really I wonder about their their
state of mind I'm wondering what these
people are doing in physics they should
be in church on Sunday you know Sunday
school you know talking to their priests
what are these people doing in physics
they don't understand
kindergarten stuff and and they want to
understand the you know these higher
Concepts I don't know where you got the
idea that a photograph is an object that
you frame as a concept what is he
listening to what is going through his
brain I have no idea it just shocks me
sometimes that you know they don't
understand something very simple
this is simple we're seeing that you got
to treat the universe as if it were a
movie run by God or whoever I don't care
father Universe it's a movie and every
frame in that movie is just
every object in the universe at a
distance from all others nothing is
moving it's like if you stop the
universe at that frame nothing is moving
okay and you just take a snapshot of the
universe you know God's camera
maybe Adam man's camera you take a
snapshot of the universe everything is
static nothing moves
okay everything is simply at a distance
from everything else separation
that's all qualitative
okay and that's a single frame in the
movie
now it turns out you start the movie
again
okay so now we get another frame you
stop it immediately so we only got
another frame in that second frame
everything is static everything is
simply at a different location from
everything else
and so you have these people and they
think they say oh but there was motion
because how did how did this particle
this Adam
moved to this new location wasn't there
motion there to move from one location
to the next
this is what's going through their tiny
Minds
that's what you have to define the
static Concepts before you define the
Dynamic Concepts
let me repeat that you have to define
the static concept before you define the
Dynamic Concepts
motion is a dynamic concept hopefully
hopefully you define it based on static
Concepts in this case location what is
motion two or more locations so when we
say look here we have one frame on the
film and it's that everything is
standing still
now uh you start the movie again and
there's only one frame the next frame
you make it as close or as distant as
you want it I don't care now we have the
next frame in the movie everything in
the universe moved a little bit right
it's in a different location meaning now
we have two locations now we have motion
because we have two frames but in each
frame all we have is location
okay and so you say well how did it get
from frame one to frame two
then it moved
what is motion two or more locations
here we have two locations we need two
frames to conceptualize motion you
cannot talk about motion
between two frames of the movie
and I hope that sank in somehow
okay there is no motion between two
frames of the movie and you can make
those two frames as close or as far
apart as you want I don't care but
people are thinking you know that
um the next location is far apart and
they say well how did it move from this
location to that location wasn't there
motion there
well what if the next frame is just
[Music]
uh a difference in location
wasn't that you say well wasn't there
motion there well what is motion Define
motion we'll know if there was motion
and you'll see that you require two
frames of the movie of The Universal
movie to Define motion that's what
you'll find
so yes you need to Define location
static Concepts before you do Define uh
Dynamic ones
okay and here's another file also along
the same lines something about motion he
says uh well I say these people have
this motion that uh motion is continuous
and he says I should note that
continuous in the case of uh case in the
sense of real analysis in mathematics
math takes mathematics uh with Bill of
Wars uh and the discrete view in which
he talks about change are not really
that different
are they well again uh the spell doesn't
understand the uh notion of the
universal movie and the notion of static
concept you need to Define location
before you Define motion you cannot jump
to low to motion and say oh but there
was motion between two locations now
there is no motion between two
contiguous frames of the universal movie
there is no motion because we haven't
defined motion yet only when we have two
locations do we have motion until then
every frame only has location as if you
stop the universe right there
okay and so yeah you need to Define uh
location static concept before you do
you find Dynamic Concepts and regarding
mathematics not that I abhor mathematics
in fact uh I hate to say it but I'm a
mathematician
I study a lot of mathematics
in college okay just that
um I think I can tell you for sure that
mathematics had nothing at all to do
with physics those are two different uh
disciplines in fact mathematics is not
even a discipline it's just a language
it's like learning Chinese okay
quantitative in this case and uh it's
nothing more than that it's just a
language it's a tool that's all
mathematics is it became a religion when
they created geometry because then they
started to apply
mathematics to physical things and they
said oh we can measure an angle here we
can measure the side let's calculate
that's when they got into trouble and
from there they expanded into what is
known today as mathematical physics
which includes geometry as one of its
branches
no math is math physics is physics never
between shall meet
with that I'll see you next Sunday